my dad you know he was a big money guy
i'm like okay
you love money so much watch me out
gross you and your whole damn family
to combined often times when you hit
bottom
you bounce and that's where i think
the power is when it comes to lousy
moods
and possibly even bigger mental health
problems
there's one thing you may not be
considering want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got michael jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe
life and learn the six ways to get out
of a bad mood
and crush your day
all right let's kick it off with way
number one rethink comfort food with
steven gundry
have you ever had one of those days
where you just wake up on the wrong side
of the bed
you're cranky grumpy and just plain off
the worst part when you're having a
lousy day can just seem like
nothing is going to turn your mood
around maybe you try and nap
meditation exercise but still the mood
just sticks around well when it comes to
lousy moods
and possibly even bigger mental health
problems
there's one thing you may not be
considering it all comes down to one
really interesting scientific phenomenon
the gut brain axis
now i could talk about the gut brain
access all day
but for now i'll just explain the quick
version
to put it simply your gut and your brain
actually communicate with one another
through your nervous system
it's actually pretty strong two-way
communication
for example when you're stressed your
brain
lets your gut know which is why so many
people report having a
nervous stomach when there's something
stressful going on
and when your stomach is upset for
whatever reason it can actually impact
your
mood your energy level and even your
ability to focus it's no
wonder some scientists call your gut
your second
brain it's got such a profound effect on
the way
you feel body and mind
which is why if you're struggling with a
lousy mood it might be time to look at
your
diet and no i'm not just talking about
grabbing some carb
heavy comfort food though a piece of
dark chocolate
is scientifically proven to lift your
spirits
i'm talking about rethinking comfort
food
and going for options that comfort your
gut
because when your gut is balanced your
mood stays
lifted after all some of the most
important hormones are produced
in the gut like serotonin the feel good
hormone
and gaba which helps you manage stress
and anxiety in fact
gaba is actually produced by your gut
bugs
clearly keeping your gut happy goes a
long way to
keeping your spirits lifted way number
two connect with nature with robin
sharma
one of my favorite protocols is the
daily
nature walk i love walking in the woods
i often listen to audiobooks in the
woods
i call it walk reading while walking
reading while walking so i go to this
place
it's sort of my creative forest there's
not a lot of people in there
and i walk for one hour i breathe in the
air
i look at the lush scenery i listen to a
different
audiobook i it's almost like a walking
meditation as well sometimes i don't
listen to an audiobook
and i just walk and i touch the earth
it's almost like i'm
thanking the earth connecting with the
soil yes i'm wearing shoes
i don't want to get too esoteric here
but there's a lot of really good
research saying
if you want to boost your immune system
you want to boost your happiness
you want to release serotonin dopamine
you want to release the fear
hormone called cortisol walk in nature
and so when i walk i connect with nature
and like i say
i know i'm not being very elegant in
this mastery session
i'm just being real but i listen to
audiobooks and then other times i do a
walking meditation where i
feel my feet on the soil you know what i
do other times
if there's something i'm confused about
i sort of just talk it out
it's like i'm talking out loud trying to
work it out
if i'm in pain i get the negative
negative energy out of my system
by just releasing it by talking about it
i also and i know this sounds a little
unorthodox but i i do like a
a walking blessing meditation
so while i'm walking i sort of challenge
myself to come up with 50 things i'm
grateful for
and again i verbalize those because it's
only me and the squirrels and the
it's only me and the squirrels in the
woods and so i say i'm grateful for
my family i'm grateful for my health i'm
grateful for work that feeds my soul
i'm grateful for the sunset i watched
last night
i'm grateful for my team i'm grateful
for my business i'm grateful for
the travels that i get to take i'm
grateful for the people that i've served
and literally while i'm walking i say
out loud
i am grateful for i hope it doesn't
sound strange for you
because it's an incredible protocol to
install way number three
do cardio with joe rogan and any um
long-term cardiovascular exercise you
get this
it's like we did you know last last
october we did the sober october thing
where we had
this crazy fitness challenge so all of
us were doing cardio like five hours a
day
like really crazy amounts of cardio and
one of the things that tom segura and i
both agreed on is like
the the amount of internal
chatter dissipates to zero like you have
no anxiety it goes i didn't realize i
had any anxiety
until that happened and then i was like
god it goes to zero
it goes to nothing like when you do like
five hours
on a treadmill or just running just
run when you when it's done man there's
this like piece
of mind that comes with that this uh
release of endorphins that's incredibly
addictive because that feeling is so
pleasing so it's not that it doesn't
it doesn't feel good to get out of bed
and
and to just push when you don't want to
but the end result feels amazing
also if you want to have confidence and
self love check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below one of the
real reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us
is because we are afraid of being judged
it's good to treat other people the way
you would like to be treated yourself
it's like a
golden rule and there's a reason for it
and that reason is that we're connected
and when you change yourself and your
own behaviors
and how you think you're going to change
everything way number four
use anger as fuel with henry rollins
what powers me it's not money it's not
ambition
it's anger i'm one of those people i i
i wish there was a better way to say it
but i i it's
vengeance you laughed at me in high
school man you said i was going to be
anything
really like watch this like that's
still pushing you at 56. i hate to say
it oh yeah
40 40 years later oh yeah all of it like
you know
my dad you know he was a big money guy
i'm like okay
you love money so much watch me out
gross you and your whole damn family
to combined and i don't even care about
it i just like achieving it
and it's one of the reasons when the
agent goes okay
five shows on one off i'm like oh no no
man no no that's a day off you put a
show in there
like why because like screw that man
watch me do
put two shows on that night well you
think i can't i'm just
like i said i set up adversarial
relationships i'm not against you or
anything
i'm just saying like i have to have
something to push against like a
schedule that there's like
the schedules like godzilla like you
can't
finish this like really man i'm gonna
serve you up and eat you
every day like a steak and i just have
to have that and so i'm getting back
and it's i think of all the people i was
in bands with i have to crush them
everyone i grew up with i have to
powderize them
wow that's such a weird motivation it
sucks it's immature it's like it's 11
year old sandbox
wow you're aware of it yeah that which
makes it even stranger because it's not
something that you're just operating
under
well you know you have it's it's
controlling you and you don't understand
it i quite enjoy it yeah you use it yeah
like if i you know i i'm not an actor
but i go for acting parts i'm like
basically
going in there and winging it and i get
you know i get to go up for like really
big parts there's a little bit of
trepidation
knowing i'm going in there but then i
think like oh yeah
sony whatever man line it up
and i almost like run out of my car like
you know where are you at man
and i'm not trying to impress you i'm a
tough guy because i'm not i just need to
it just needs to be trying to tell me i
can't
and i it that informs that
everything i do like instead of just
dialing my radio show in i work on that
sucker for like five hours
it has to be all hand picked no that
song not that one this one
and i make like three drafts of it it's
intense it's one of the reasons why i
live alone
is like i work all the time like hey
come out on this weekend no i'm it's 7
p.m on a friday i'm working
like i'm not i'm not constant yeah
no i'm not fun to hang out with do you
vacation ever where you just chill no i
i can't
intellectually and existentially i can't
understand the idea of a vacation
i i make a joke on stage i said i want
to come back 10 pounds lighter with an
internal parasite
i i i want to come back with like a scar
where the spear kind of grazed me
and eight great stories and a dangerous
insect in my bag
i don't want to sit on the beach and
soak in the rays
i want to get sunburned by you know
being in the desert
and like you know figuring out how the
sun won't try and kill me by noon
that's the sahara and so that's how i go
about it
so part of your motivation is actually
the perception by other people of what
you're doing
like understanding that what you're
doing is so undeniable
the volume that you're putting out and
the intensity yeah the intensity so
undeniable
like i'll show you yeah absolutely wow
that's so weird even with people who
like me
like yay henry's here i'm like yeah i'm
here check it out check this out
yeah here's a place you won't go and
it's not that i have any aggression
towards these people i just
i just want to burn brightly yeah and
it's not about money
it's it's not about i'm better than you
because i i don't think i'm better than
anybody
i just want to explode as much as
possible
and i think to my audience it's to their
benefit he's like that dude's gonna go
out there to a place i don't wanna go
he's gonna come back with 10 great
photos
and a story about how he really lost his
foot it's great
and like put me in coach that's the game
i want to play that's what i go for
way number five get present with mel
robbins
often times when you hit bottom you
bounce
and that's where i think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one
chapter ends you always have the power
to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you
you have the power to learn how to love
yourself and if there's one thing that
covid
19 has done regardless of
whatever devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all
to experience the great pause
and i read that in a medium article and
i love that idea
of a pause because i think in 2020 our
lives have gotten
so fast and so digital
and when you are forced to pause and get
present and to slow down
you are reminded of what's actually
important and what's important is your
health
what's important is your family and your
friends
what's important is whether or not you
are taking care of yourself and
thinking positive thoughts versus
negative thoughts
the world gave us a gigantic experiment
where we got to practice and get to
continue to practice
the most important skill in the planet
which is emotional
resilience the ability to face hard
and actually be okay the ability to face
the uncertain
and redirect your attention on things
that you
know that are certain and way number six
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is use your cookie jar with david
goggins
whenever times got hard my mind said
you're not good enough right let's go
right so my mind wasn't
my eyes my mind weren't connecting right
so how do you combat that
so how you can bat that is this i call
it the cookie jar
okay you have to remind yourself
we all have a story we've all all of us
have gone through very hard times
but we're when we're in a hard time our
mind has a way of forgetting
what all we've overcome i have a way
of taking one second when i want to quit
and say okay you endured this
so i look at my life and how i came up
as the ultimate training ground
versus most people look at it as why
what was me god why exactly why
right i had to flip this upside down and
say hang on a second
god was training me to be one of the
baddest men on the planet
absolutely right that's how he this was
this was my journey
now i've got a special bonus clip on how
you can raise your
environment that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i wanna know which of these six mood
boosters are you
going to use the next time you're in a
bad mood let me know put it down in the
comments below and if you made it this
far
in a video you're still here watching i
want to celebrate you because believe
nation we don't just watch videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're going to
take action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag
believe down in the comments and tell me
where you're from because i want to
celebrate
you your environment is keeping you
where you are
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you
exactly where you are right now
the people you listen to the media that
you consume
the habits that you do daily all of them
all of them are designed to keep you
exactly where you are
so if you want to raise your game if you
want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment
i've changed a lot over the course of
having this youtube channel
the people who've known me the best and
the longest especially in the past two
to three years have said evan you've
changed a lot
for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more
more poise you're a better speaker you
you're pushing the boundaries more
you've changed
what happened how do i get that for
myself right people want it
whenever you are off growing and
learning and evolving
other people they want it they want a
taste of it they want to do it too
because we are not designed to just
photocopy our lives over and over and
over again
so how did i get it i paid more
attention to my environment
i paid more attention to my daily
routines i paid more attention to the
people that i hang around with
it's important so looking at my physical
environment right
look at the look at this office look at
the people behind me this all means
something to me
looking at the new design that i've had
here below putting things like my neck
braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me i walk into this
every day my youtube videos the channel
i create for myself
the the people that i profile i'm
learning from i feel like i have gary
vee
in my head i have oprah winfrey in my
ear i've got elon musk telling me what
to do
pushing me to try to get better i hear
these people talking about
you have to be courageous you have to be
bold you have to believe in yourself
more
and when i feel myself being nervous
about something boom boom boom boom boom
it's a push that i have to do it and so
i've designed my life i've designed my
environment
to help push me to get to the next step
[Music]
if you want to know the best habits that
make people successful check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there my life changed a couple years ago
when i discovered something called the
progress
principle the one habit that you must
develop